the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
good morning everybody
today we're going to continue our
journey and looking at the tens sort of
basic types of reactions on that you
will encounter when studying basic
metabolism and they're all found on your
vitamin bottle so here are the
Flintstones Flintstones vitamins I like
Flintstones vitamins because you don't
have to swallow them you can chew them
and today what I'm going to start
talking about is redox chemistry what
are the two redox active cofactors and
what we will focus on today is vitamin
b2 which is riboflavin and vitamin b3
which is niacin okay so we're going to
talk about oxidation and reduction and
what the cofactors are that involved in
these transformations in all primary
metabolic pathways so the first thing I
want to do is introduce you to these two
cofactors the structure of the cofactors
then what I'll do is focus on a
comparison of their properties and then
I want to focus on the mechanism of how
these cofactors work and once you master
these concepts you really will encounter
them over and over again through
throughout your journey and metabolism
and you will be familiar with the kinds
of chemical transformations that are
occurring ok so the first cofactor comes
from niacin and it is nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide in the reduced
state or nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide in the oxidized state and
as with all cofactors the vitamins are a
precursor to the cofactor and they have
to be converted inside the cell to the
active
form of the cofactor so if you look at
nadh let me draw that structure for you
and then i'm going to show you that well
most well the structure is quite complex
most of it is not fault in the chemical
transformations and so we'll put a big R
group on most of the cofactor and you
don't have to memorize the structures of
any of these cofactors and that you will
be given the structures whenever you
have any kind of exercise to carry out
so the form of the vitamin is actually
an a nicotinamide ring and then it needs
to be metabolized to the structure on
drawing now which has the nicotinamide
ring attached to a ribose ring which is
then attached to adp which are all
familiar with and I'm just going to
abbreviate the adenosine part of the
molecule with an ad so this part of the
molecule we're gonna call for the rest
of this exercise today the R group
because it's not involved in the
chemistry and really all of the
chemistry happens in this part of the
molecule this is the business end and
this is the reduced form of the cofactor
NADH okay so in addition to the reduced
form since we're doing oxidation and
reduction you need to know what the
oxidized form is and the oxidized form
is the following where you need to lose
a couple of electrons and a couple of
protons out of this ring to generate
this nicotinamide ring and again this
part of the molecule is indicated as R
and then you retain a positive charge so
again this is the part of the molecule
we're going to be focusing on and this
is the oxidized form of the cofactor
okay so what I want to do now
show you how this compares to the second
form of the organic cofactor that you
will encounter over and over again and
metabolism and this is fadh2 or FM and H
- that's the reduced form versus FM nf8
sorry F ad or F M and okay so this is
one of the most complicated of all the
cofactors and you'll see that it has a
very complex ring structure called an I
so elds oxygen ring which I'm drawing
now that most of you have likely never
encountered before and when you look at
the structure of this molecule you
probably will have no idea about where
the chemical reactivity is and I'll show
you where the chemical reactivity is and
how we know that in a few few minutes
okay so attached to this nitrogen is
more complex structure with a sugar
where X can be phosphate this is called
the flavin mononucleotide reduced this
is the reduced form and if X is equal to
adp this is flavin adenine dinucleotide
reduce and i want to point out that ATP
is present in both nadh and fadh2 as it
is present actually in coenzyme a and in
ATP so adp plays a central role in
almost all the chemical transformations
the ten reactions we actually talked
about that is central to all of primary
metabolism however in this case again
this part of the
molecule we're gonna call our is not
involved in the chemistry so the
business end of the molecule is
indicated here and so this is the
business end and this is the reduced
state okay so this cofactor has to be
good able to toggle between the reduced
state and the oxidized state and if you
look at the oxidized state so I'm going
to indicate this whole part of the
molecule is are you could see a change
in this part of the I so L oxygen ring
that is you've lost approach you've us
two protons and two electrons to form
the oxidized form of this cofactor now I
also want to give you the nomenclature
for the ISO Al Aqsa zine ring because
I'm going to tell you where the chemical
reactive positions are and so you need
to know the numbering of the ring and so
this is the N one position this is two
three four this carbon between these two
positions is called the C for a this is
carbon C four and this is the n five
position and we'll see that C four and
five become important in the overall
chemistry of the transformation okay so
these are the two cofactors again this
one is considerably more complex than
this one but what I want to do and
you'll see both of these cofactors used
over and over again and break down or
biosynthesis of sugars break down or but
biosynthesis of fatty acids the question
is what when are they used and what is
the distinction between these cofactors
so what I want to do is compare the
properties of these two cofactors and
then specifically give you an example of
how these cut each of these cofactors
works so on one side I'll have nad NADH
and the other side will have F ad
the oxidized form and fadh2 the reduced
form so we have nad NADH fa D fadh2 and
I want to compare these two cofactors
and the first thing I want to compare is
the chemistry and what we will see is
nad NADH always does two electron
chemistry all of the time on the other
hand F ad fadh2 can do either one
electron chemistry or two electron
chemistry and in fact a function of
Flavin's
in inside the cell is the major mediator
between something that can donate two
electrons and can something that can
accept only a single electron so
something that could donate two
electrons would be an ad NADH which I'll
show you in a minute and something that
can accept only a single electron or
like metals
like if you think back to hemoglobin and
you think about the iron 3 state going
to the iron two states so so there's a
big distinction between the two the
second thing is we need ever since we're
doing oxidation and reduction we need to
think about the reduction potentials
okay and if you think about the
reduction potential of nad NADH it turns
out to be minus 320 volt millivolts and
what you need to recall from freshman
chemistry is that the more positive the
number the easier it is to reduce so the
fact that this is minus 320 millivolts
tells you that nad likes to be in the
oxidized State the NAD State on the
other hand f ad fadh2 can vary between
400 - 450 millivolts to plus 150
millivolts so this is a huge difference
in reduction potential 600 millivolts
okay so why is that true it turns out
that if you look at the hundreds of
enzyme structures that we now have we've
gone through a structural revolution
last 15 years all of the structures
where any DNA th bind our homologous to
each other and in fact these structures
don't have anything designed into the
structure where they perturb the redox
potential the redox potential remains
the same regardless of what protein it's
by enzyme it's bound to on the other
hand Flavin's don't maintain a single
type of binding site they have five or
six different kinds of binding sites and
that's because the flavin chemistry as
you can see from this isoh l occitane
ring i introduced to you just a minute
ago is much more diverse it does much
more diverse chemistry and in fact the
active site can tune the redox potential
to to do so it facilitates either two
electron chemistry or one electron
chemistry or a combination of the two
okay so the next thing that's really
important in thinking about any the two
cofactors and their differences is that
nad NADH can act as a substrate that is
nad NADH is nad for example would act as
an oxidant of some second substrate
every time you have an oxidant you have
to have something that's going to be
oxidized okay and during turnover of
oxidized to reduced States the
substrates and products must come on and
off the enzyme so they dissociate in
every single turnover fa D fadh2 on the
other hand is always tightly bound or
covalently bound to the substrate and so
that means that if fa d gets reduced to
fadh2 it doesn't associate so you need
to have a way in the active site of the
enzyme where the fadh2 can be reoxidized
again that's quite distinct from nad
NADH and the third thing I want to the
fourth thing I want to talk about just
briefly and this is what I'm gonna focus
the rest of this little section on is
the mechanisms by which these cofactors
work and so out of all of the cofactors
you're going to be introduced to in this
little this section in general on the
ten basic reactions this is probably the
simplest and nad NADH involves hydride
transfer and proton transfer so a
hydride is a hydrogen with a pair of
electrons and a proton and we'll see
that in a minute with FA D fadh2 the
chemistry is considerably more
complicated but what I will show you is
that it can also do hydride transfer and
when it does hydride transfer it does it
to the n5 position so if you go if we go
back for a second and look at the flavin
in the nomenclature this is the n5
position I also pointed out you can do
si for a chemistry which is in your
lexicon but we're not going to discuss
further today so you can do n 5
chemistry by hydride transfer and you
can also do si for a chemistry which you
will see later on when you when you
start talking about primary metabolic
pathways okay so what I want to do now
is focus on a specific example and show
you what the basic chemistry is with
these two systems focusing on hydride
transfer chemistry so an example I've
chosen to briefly look at is what I
would call an ending to the glycolysis
pathway glycolysis is you already know
is breakdown of sugar under anaerobic
conditions so under Arabic conditions
what happens is when all this energy is
given off when you break down your sugar
it's stored in chemical bonds NADH the
NADH then goes into the respiratory
chain and the respiratory chain
ultimately transfers this energy to
convert oxygen into water which is
really it releases a huge amount of
energy which is a then trapped to make
the energy currency of the cell
ATP okay so we're under anaerobic
conditions and we need to be able to
recycle and keep because nad NADH comes
off and on the enzyme at every single
turnover you really need to be able to
recycle the reduce form back to the
oxidized form so glycolysis can actually
continue okay so what happens at the
ending one anaerobic ending of
glycolysis is you need a proton plus
NADH so that's the reduced form that's
generated during glycolysis plus the
molecule called pyruvate this is a
molecule you're gonna see over and over
again over the course of the semester
whose structure you need to remember so
this is the reduced state and this is
the oxidized state and NADH is going to
reduce this ketone to an alcohol and it
itself becomes oxidized so nad loses a
hydride and a proton to form NADH lose a
hydrogen proton to form nad and you
generate lactic acid okay where this
hydrogen from the nad as a hydride is
going to get transferred to the carbon
of the carbonyl and this proton in some
way comes from solution and it's picked
up a proton and the IMP from the active
site of the enzyme now another point I
wanted to make which you will encounter
again over the course of thinking about
coupling reactions and metabolism to
make them favorable is that with nad
NADH cofactor you always have to think
about the proton so you need a proton to
have a balanced equation that means that
if you're a pH 6 versus pH 8 the
concentration of the species changes
dramatically and that can affect whether
the Librium of the overall reaction lies
so you need to keep in the back of the
mind
your mind that there's a proton with nad
NADH systems okay and so this is nad but
it turns out that Flavin's can also
catalyze the same type of reaction so in
the case of this particular enzyme it's
found in eukaryotic systems it's found
also in prokaryotic systems but in the
case of the flavin dependent enzymes
it's only found in bacterial systems and
so the reaction goes more favorably in
the direction I'm writing it now but
again it's an equilibrium reaction will
you take lactate so this is now the
reduced state and so you now have F m
and okay so this is the form of the
cofactor that's used for the specific
enzyme but the chemistry is same with f
MN and F ad and so this needs to get
oxidized and it gets oxidized to form
pyruvate and so f MN gets reduced to
form FM and h2 so both of these are
capable of catalyzing the same redox
chemistry and this is consistent with
what I've told you before about the
redox potentials so nad NADH is always
in this region but you can see that F ad
fadh2 also covers that region as well so
many of the chemistry's between these
two cofactors can be overlapping and
you'll see this and in for example fatty
acid oxidation and fatty acid
biosynthesis and it really is not clear
at all which one of these of the redox
chemistry you could use nature in fact
could use different cofactors and
different organisms okay but we know
what the cofactors are in human systems
because we've purified all the enzymes
and study the cofactor requirements okay
so this is the reaction I want to focus
on and what I forgot to tell you to
maybe make this more relevant to some of
you
I guess since this is what you do when
you go to college nowadays is most of
you have heard about yeast that under
anaerobic conditions make your friend to
make you happy and cheery when you're
when you're having tough times at MIT
you want to drink some ethanol yeast are
able to convert glucose all the way down
under anaerobic conditions into ethanol
and in fact uses the cofactor NADH to in
two steps convert pyruvate into a
molecule called acetaldehyde and then
the NADH converts the outset now the
Hide into ethanol which is the major
ingredient of beer and wine okay so what
I want to do now is very briefly then
focus on the chemistry of how NADH
actually works okay so if we're now
going to look at the chemistry of this
and the mechanism let's start with
purveyed and you need to go back and you
need to think about the carbonyl
chemistry you've been introduced to when
talking about the Clay's and reaction
and the aldol reaction and we spent a
lot of time on carbonyl chemistry
because it's central to everything in
biochemistry and so you remember that a
carbonyl is polarized where the
electrons like to reside on the oxygen
leaving a deficiency of electrons on the
carbon of the carbonyl and so one can
draw a resonance structure this is the
predominant structure but these
resonance structures are often tell you
something about where the molecule is
most reactive and so what we've done is
oxygen is electronegative and likes to
can accommodate electrons in its
orbitals so it forms a resonance
structure like this leaving behind
electron deficiency at the carbon and so
we want to reduce this carbonyl to an
alcohol and this is done with the
reduced form of the cofactor so again in
every redox can
mystery this is the oxidized form this
is the reduced form and so now the
question is how does this chemistry
happen so let me point out here and this
is something you'll hear about it over
and over again in basic metabolism but
these two hydrogen's and this is the one
two three four position of the
nicotinamide ring are not equivalent and
why aren't they equivalent they're not
equivalent because all of the chemistry
happens in the active site of an enzyme
that it's chiral so these hydrogen's are
Pro chiral and because they sit in a
chiral environment it makes these
hydrogen's act like they're chiral so
all chemistry with NADH is
stereospecific depending on the active
site only one of these two protons is
involved and hydride transfer so if you
look at the chemistry now we're set up
to deliver a proton with a pair of
electrons that's a hydride to this
carbon of the carbonyl so we have a
hydride transfer and now we have the
electron density sitting on the oxygen
and so likely then in the active site of
the enzyme you have a general acid
catalyst which is able to then donate a
proton and remember I told you that nad
NADH involves hydride transfer and
proton transfer so what you generate
then is o H where this hydrogen comes
from a general acid catalyst and the
active site and you have the hydride
transfer coming from the NADH to
generate lactic acid and now what you've
generated is the oxidized form of the
nad so reduced form oxidized reduced
form oxidized okay so this is the
general reaction and all any DNA D H
enzymes involved this simple type of a
metro
Tron's hydrides and protons okay now
what I want to do is show you one of the
many types of reactions that Flavin's
can undergo and again focusing on
hydride transfer reactions and it recall
to you that again the redox potentials
of the Flavin's in the nad NADH overlap
so this is always minus 320 but this has
a span of redox potentials and in fact
what you will see when you look at basic
metabolism is often FA D is reduced by
NADH okay and so these two partner up to
do chemistry and so what I want to do
now is show you the chemistry with a
flavin in NADH if we go back and we look
at our oxidized form of the flavin okay
and when again I'm not going to draw out
all this structure remember there's a
lot of spinach here and there's also
some spinach here this is the business
end of the molecule and remember I told
you the business end of the molecule is
the n5 and the c4 a position and so now
we have our nad NADH sorry so this is
the oxidized form this is the reduced
form and so nad NADH goes through
hydride proton transfers does it stereo
specifically and the question is where
does the chemistry happen with the
flavin and the chemistry happens stereo
specifically so each enzyme will be
different you can figure out what the
stereochemistry is at the n5 position so
here's again the n5 position so you have
hydride transfer to the n5 position and
now you can pick up a proton or not at
this position I'm going to show you the
pKa
back and you look at the handout in the
lexicon you'll see the pKa of this
nitrogen isn't under physiological
conditions about 7 so it can be
protonated or not protonated and so what
then happens is you end up with the
reduced form where this hydrogen is
transferred to the n5 position and you
could pick up a hydrogen here from a H
leaving you with a so this proton mayor
this may or may not be protonated
depending on the active site of the
enzyme that it was and so then what you
also have here is the oxidized form of
NADH now those of you who are paying
attention to what I was just saying with
the reduction of pyruvate to lactate I
just went through this whole big spiel
about how you wanted to take advantage
of the fact that carbonyls are polarized
Delta plus Delta minus and that the
nucleophile this case the hydride is
always being transferred to the electron
deficient carbon not to the oxygen that
already has a lot of electron density so
you might be asking yourself well why
doesn't this hydride get transferred to
this position ok this is a position if
you look at this and you take it out of
context of the ISO Al Aqsa zine ring
this looks remarkably similar to this
carbonyl and in fact this is where your
chemical intuition falls apart and you
need to know that you don't have
chemical intuition about those people
who spent 40 years studying ISO al aqsa
singh's rings and this is a complex
heterocyclic molecule where I think most
chemists when looking at this for the
first time had no clue as to what the
reactive positions were and what the
chemistry was and they spent you know in
the 1970s and 1980s spent decade
figuring out the chemistry
Flavin's so I'm telling you what the
answer is it does there's experimental
evidence that supports this that in the
case of NADH hydride is transferred to
the n5 position to give you the reduced
form and the oxidized form of nad okay
so I hope I've gotten you excited and
interested about the two redox active
cofactors that you're going to encounter
over and over again during your journey
through primary metabolic pathways FA D
and nad and I hope I've taught you
something about the chemistry of how
these two cofactors work and you'll get
plenty of practice with these cofactors
over the rest of the semester